foreign
the moments leading up to a deadly
shooting are caught on camera after an
attempted Grand Theft Auto suspect
points a gun at police
hey hey stop it drop it stop that
get back get back
it all started when a 9-1-1 call came in
to Los Angeles dispatch at about 5 30 in
the morning on August 13th the caller
reported someone was trying to steal his
vehicle yeah this is an American
somebody is feeling oh my God
stealing your car
yeah if you can find myself
okay what is the address
Hoover Street
okay
it's a house
okay do you know this person
no
okay what kind of vehicle is it
it's a Toyota 4Runner
what color
it's Black the man on the line told
dispatch the suspect was still inside
the vehicle
sitting your driveway
yeah he can get out because here I can
handle peace
okay uh is he white like a saturation
is he white black Hispanic or Asian
uh it looks like it's funny to me okay
what color shirt is he wearing
I'm not sure I'm not sure I can see it
but I know it's inside after that
officers put out a call for a possible
Grand Theft Auto abbreviated as GTA via
their radio 77 unit possible attempt GTA
63 South Hoover Street suspect is a male
Hispanic sitting inside of the PR's
black Toyota 4Runner when officers
arrived on the scene they approached the
vehicle because the windows were tinted
they couldn't see inside body camera
video shows an officer open the car door
before quickly realizing someone was
inside holding a gun that man inside the
vehicle was later identified as 25 year
old obon Perdomo
oh Pandora
hey hey stop it drop it stop that
get back
up
immediately officers call for more
backup and also for pair Domo to drop
the weapon
it dropped the gun
is responding to the backup response
southbound from the second property on
the West Side just because inside the
vehicle within minutes more officers
arrive on the scene
hey
just just read a play to cover
he's still in the back seat
it's climbing over
a redeploy to the car partner
for that car First Responders again call
for Perdomo to drop the weapon
it's a gun on the leave the gun in the
car step out with your hands up
step out with your hands up
step out of the vehicle with your hands
up
step out yeah we got two
step out
drop that on the ground
drop it
[Music]
that was a 20.
block
Drop It On The Ground
put that down
put it down put it down
after that one of the officers begins
commands in Spanish eventually paradomo
walks toward police but still doesn't
drop the gun drop that on the ground
[Applause]
don't try Spanish real quick
tell them to drop all that yeah
stop what I eat
quality
dash camera video captured the same
moments from another angle yeah
what is this
when peridomo still doesn't put down the
gun officers fire a less lethal 40
millimeter shotgun with foam rounds
toward him hey 40 standby
foreign
[Music]
but paradomo still doesn't cooperate
with officers so they fire a second foam
round
by 40 standby
he's right in the way to the gate
swallow
hello
40 standby again paradomo doesn't drop
the weapon when officers fire a third
less lethal round at him Perdomo points
a weapon back at officers after that
they opened fire shooting Perdomo
[Applause]
drop it
foreign
officials again call for peridomo to
stay still before approaching
[Music]
hey are we gonna approach
ES
don't reach hey let him know not to
reach
[Music]
ES
after the shooting First Responders
performed CPR on peridomo but he was
later pronounced dead right now the
shooting is still under investigation
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie